hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers Salman who is a
recent graduate in HR and got offered a
job as an HR clerk that he feels might
be a little bit below his skill level
and he was asking me if that was fair or
not and what I would suggest doing so
for me I always recommend going and
starting your own business but if you're
going to go get a job I would do it to
learn something so make sure that you're
going to be learning something at
whatever job you're going to so this may
be an entry-level job but is this
something where you're going to be able
to learn some skills that will be able
to further your development the other
thing I look at if you're going from a
job you know career point of view is are
there opportunities to learn and advance
so maybe boring entry-level stuff now
but is it a reputable company where
you'll be able to advance and you know
move up as you prove yourself so
obviously when we're really hard show
the boss that you're doing a good job
and other opportunities to expand or not
some companies are you know really
forward moving in that respect and
others are not so you know look at that
company and the last thing we do is you
know if you're looking at certain your
own business which I always encourage
people to do then is their skills that
you're going to learn from that job that
will help you launch your business or
not right if you're doing kind of really
boring stuff that you're not going to
learn anything from then maybe that
won't help you down the line but if
there are skills that you're going to be
able to learn then maybe that could help
you so can't just give a yes or no
answer I guess it depends on the
scenario but hopefully that helps you if
you guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up below and it also love to hear
feedback if you don't leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for next
episode